speaking of people who are almost as old
as lawrence brooks
but who unfortunately don't have any
wisdom joe biden
this is a weird story people were
tweeting this to me even on my vacation
and i had to see it because i thought i
was living
in a kind of bizarro world universe you
know over my vacation i didn't shave
so i had like a kind of little goatee
and then i saw my evil twin
he was the one without the goatee but
and i was the one with the goatee but it
was my evil twin
t.j ducklow joe biden's national press
secretary
went on fox news when on brett baier's
show and was asked specifically
what joe biden would have done
differently on
coronavirus he had no answer the vice
president was not against the travel ban
first of all second of all
let's let's remember and it wasn't uh
brett let's remember an important
distinction
donald trump was the president of the
united states it was on donald trump i'm
asking you okay joe biden
donald trump it was on donald trump he
would take action to actually protect
the american people he closed the joke
traveled
joe biden wrote an op-ed in usa today in
january warning that the threat was
coming
joe biden said in february that donald
trump should get people on the ground
in china what did what did donald trump
do donald trump was praising china
donald trump was praising president xi's
response saying that they had it under
control when clearly he knew
as we now know from bob woodward they
did not have it under control he should
have been protecting the american people
he should have been putting real plans
in place so let me just clarify confront
this
incredibly dangerous understand let me
just clarify you're saying that joe
biden
was for closing down travel from china
when the president did it
uh joe biden has been clear and i can
send you the fact checks if they're
helpful
brad joe biden has been clear that he
was not against that travel ban but he
was for it
joe biden has been clear about this
brett again i can send i can send you
the fact checks
if they're helpful this has been fact
checked into oblivion
it only got worse from there you see he
can't give an answer he just talks about
the fact checks
people people did point out at this
point that mr ducklow bears a striking
resemblance to me they were asking
if he was me you know i if i and
i guess i just owe the people an
explanation i'll just come i'll just
come clean
well you all thought i was on vacation i
i became joe biden's national press
secretary
um i i figured right now that's that's
the only way i can get on fox these days
is uh you know just pretend to be a
liberal and uh and joe biden's press
secretary so that's what i did okay i'm
sorry
i'm sorry that i did it but i thought it
would be a fun troll of the joe biden
campaign and obviously joe biden would
have no idea
because he doesn't know what planet he's
on these days
i gotta tell you though i tj ducklow i'm
a pretty weak
liberal spokesman because uh you know i
clearly had no answer to that question
and the reason is bret bear got to give
him i mean this guy is so great this guy
is so great at his job he's
pretty much a straight shooter when it
comes to these things he says okay
you're saying that he was always clear
that he didn't oppose the travel ban
so was he for the travel ban was he for
it
and the answer is absolutely not how do
we know that we have joe biden on record
decrying trump's travel ban from china
when
it was instituted as hysterical
xenophobia
coronavirus emitted from china
a national emergency you know worldwide
alerts
the american people need to have a
president who they can trust what he
says about it
that he is going to act rationally about
it
in moments like this this is where the
credibility of president
is most needed as he explains what we
should and should not do
this is no time for donald trump's
record of
hysteria xenophobia hysterical
xenophobia
no time for that no time by the way to
say it wasn't just joe biden at the same
time nancy pelosi
during the height of the rising
coronavirus nancy pelosi goes to
chinatown in san francisco no mask
ton of people all around and says come
on down to chinatown
bill de blasio doing the same kind of
stuff in new york all of these liberals
were completely down playing the virus
trying to keep travel open with china
trying to get people out out in the open
they're still doing it with the blm
riots they're saying yeah go out and
riot and all be together
but if you ever show up to anything
conservative then everyone's going to
die of coronavirus so
they have no answer whatsoever i do feel
a little bit a little bit sorry for mr
ducklow because the campaign is only as
good as the candidate
most of the time okay and joe biden as a
candidate
is completely failing he was asked a
question about whether or not he's
losing a step or two whether he loses
his train of thought
and what does he do he says it's
completely ridiculous and while he's
explaining why he doesn't lose his train
train of thought he loses his strain of
thought
just look at us okay just look at us
who seems to be in shape who's able to
move around
who's i mean this idea of you know
slow joe
i anyway i i shouldn't laugh about it
because uh
anyway donald trump just look at us both
watch us
and determine whether or not you think
i'm misleading anyone not you personally
but the public
you know look at me well you think i
would lose my
train of thought what do you think
people would say people have said that i
would lose my train of thought
just because i saw a butterfly what you
mean like a monarch butterfly
one of those cute little black and
orange butterflies fluttering all around
you every which way kind of blowing
around in the wind and it's so nice on a
nice
light breezy day at the end of august
labor day weekend is a great time
i love labor day love american life what
are we talking about what are we talking
about again
i hope you enjoyed this segment of the
michael knowles show and you should know
on september 28th
the michael knowles show will be moving
from the daily wire youtube channel to
the michael noll show youtube channel
because that just makes sense doesn't
it's right there it's right there in the
name
there is a link in the description below
head on over
subscribe to the michael noel show
youtube channel ring the bell
you will never miss another video
[Music]